ich bin der auffassung dass unsere
diskussionskultur in deutschland
dringend renovierungsbedürftig ist sie
ist einem aggressiven krieg der worte
gewichen nicht mal die meinung des
anderen es interessant sondern es wird
sofort gegen seine person
agitiert herabgewürdigt attackiert ohne
inhaltlich über das zu sprechen was
überhaupt gesagt hat das ist in dieser
runde hier glücklicherweise völlig
anders aber die lebenswirklichkeit ist
auch dass wir über relativ harmlos
politische themen kaum noch
diskutieren können ohne auch persönliche
beleidigungen und pöbeleien über uns
ergehen lassen zu müssen ich habe eine
cannabis freigabe diskussionen hinter
mir die wirklich unfassbar ist den
ganzen teilnehmen denn die da mich
kritisiert haben und beschimpft und
bedroht haben was man mit mir alles
machen müsste den würde ich gerne zu
rufen leute es geht nicht um euer leben
es geht nur ums kicken und bei den
diskussionen um die polizei ist das ganz
genauso da wird aus jedem tropfen den
wasserhahn behörden skandal gemacht und
immer dann wenn irgendwelche videos im
netz auftauchen von polizistinnen und
polizisten
wird sofort ein urteil gefällt am besten
gegen die ganze polizei gleich und
sofort muss man auch mit maßnahmen bei
der sache ohne den sachverhalt überhaupt
aufgeklärt zu haben falls ein bisschen
mehr gelassenheit übersicht und vor
allen dingen ein bisschen mehr
diskussionskultur und auf den anderen
hören die gute den guten alten ausdruck
ich bin anderer meinung als sie den
müssen wir wieder lang erwähnt ist das
etwas was mit online hass zu tun hat wie
gehen wir mit online hassum gibt es
überhaupt genug
durchsetzungsmöglichkeiten um mit online
hass und diskriminierung umzugehen oder
ist das was anderes nein ich wollte
nichts anderes das gehört sicherlich
auch dazu aber eben leider nicht tor ich
sitze auch in manchen fernsehdebatten
noch einmal hier geht es richtig schön
kultiviert so aber in anderen
fernsehdebatten wo eine ganz normale
positionierung ich sage ihnen mal ein
beispiel ich vertrete die auffassung und
mit mir die deutsche polizeigewerkschaft
dass man das strafmündigkeit alter
herabsetzen sollte auf das zwölfte
lebensjahr da gibt es gute argumente für
und für andere argumente hat die
respektiere ich auch wenn ich sie nicht
teile aber wenn ich das nur äußere
der gesprächspartner vor laufender
fernsehkamera das ist alles afd zeug was
sie da reden das ist rechtspopulismus
dabei ist diese position der deutschen
polizeigewerkschaft so alt da gab es die
fdp doch gar nicht also es wird heute
nicht mehr über der es inhaltliche
gesprochen nicht immer aber häufig über
die inhalte nicht gesprochen sondern
sofort das scharfe schwert
rechtspopulist afd propaganda der wind
das weiter gedacht wird dann hieße das
dass die ard mit ihren thesen die
politische agenda bestimmt und dann darf
man überhaupt nichts mehr keine position
mehr vertreten die deckungsgleich ist
mit dir die manche fdp-politiker
sie waren ja eigentlich gefühlt jeden
tag zornig auf irgendetwas in ihrer
kolumne der gerechte zorn haben sie ja
immer beschrieben was falsch läuft wie
zornig konnten sie der eine sein gab es
da für sie auch grenzen dessen was herr
wendt gerade beschrieben haben sondern
finde es übrigens immer noch jeden tag
und ich kann das ja nur bestätigen was
aber dass rainer wendt gerade gesagt hat
also es geht der zivilisierte umgang
verloren wenn sie sagen ich bin jeden
tag wütend und zornig dann in meiner
kolumne dann bin ich das hier in einem
bestimmten rahmen und verlasse die
sachliche ebene nicht ich greife
menschen nicht persönlich an und ich
glaube das ist die grundregel in allem
die wir beachten müssen und die nicht
mehr beachtet wird und ich bemühe mich
auch darum argumente auszutauschen ich
freue mich auch wenn gegenargumente
kommen die ich wiederum beantworten kann
was sie jetzt beschrieben haben erlebe
ich auch sie beschreiben dass es
überhaupt nicht am argumente geht
sondern dass jemand der etwas geäußert
hat dafür einfach verachtet wird
praktisch in einer irgendeiner form
vernichtet werden soll von der von der
bildfläche verschwinden das ist wirklich
eine ganz neue entwicklung und wir haben
immer alle nach amerika geschaut und
gesagt was macht denn der tramp da und
was machen die anderen die gegen uns
sind hier ist es auch so hier ist es
auch so und die debatte wird dadurch
nicht erschwert sondern kaputt gemacht
jetzt würden wir uns alle die frage
stellen warum ist das so wissen sie
eigentlich was passiert ist ich weiß
nicht wann es angefangen hat auch nicht
aber ich weiß dass es nicht schlimmer
wird und diese wirtschaftlich immer
weiter spaltet genau weil es nun die
einen oder die anderen gibt die sich
völlig unversöhnlich gegenüberstehen
gibt wahrscheinlich noch mehr in der
lage sind dem mann gehabt haben es
natürlich so ein bisschen mit der
sogenannten aufmerksamkeit spirale oder
auch in aufmerksamkeitsökonomie zu tun
es geht schon darum aufmerksam zu sein
und es ist ja nicht nur gibt es nur noch
einen fernsehsender und 2 und wii 10
zeitung am tag sondern wir haben
natürlich durch twitter durch instagram
durch viele andere dinge das internet an
sich einen wahnsinnigen breiten kanal
oder viele kanäle die alle entweder
bespielt werden wollen die genutzt
werden und ich glaube
der genutzt sicher habt also ich mag
überhaupt nicht dazu mich zu empören
weil empörung allein löst ja keine
probleme aber das bringt uns ja
überhaupt nicht weit ja aber es gibt
natürlich auch auf die agenda kann man
gerne je lauter sie sind und je
zugespitzter sie auch sind sich davon
erhoffen das sind natürlich die
aufmerksamkeit
eines klare position ich habe also auch
immer für die freiheit der
andersdenkenden noch nicht höher denn
auch gerne zu ich habe so ein bisschen
sorge dass die menschen nur noch senden
senden senden und überhaupt nicht nur
dass er reichlich wohl aufzunehmen dass
sie dass sie weniger zu hören und ich
beobachte auch so ganz leicht das
einzelne gruppen immer mehr ihre
betroffenheit betonen ja und dass
minderheiten glauben immer lauter sein
zu müssen um gehört zuwendet dass das
nicht immer daran dürfe nicht einfach
nicht gehört viele jahrzehnte
strukturell gehört wurde habe ja das
zeigen auch menschen dazu die
deutungshoheit für gewisse dinge an sich
zu reißen und da frage ich mich immer
wer sagt denn jetzt dass du auf jeden
fall im recht ist also der andere könnte
auch recht haben das ist ehrlich aber
jeder haben weil jeder argumentation
wirklich wer bestimmt denn jetzt das
weiße keine jobs tragen dürfen zb oder
weil dieser cannabis diskussion aber es
gibt ja die einheit nicht verstanden
werden ich bin ja auch kein kind von
traurigkeit ich kann auch sehr polemisch
sagen ich kann sarkastisch sein und
zynisch und das geht alles kann man auch
sagen aber das ist etwas anderes als
mein gesprächspartner meine
gesprächspartnerin persönlich in ihrer
persönlichkeit so herabzuwürdigen so
abzunehmen das ist doch ein kommune
fehlende argumentation werden aber da
ist das gekommen als weil ich gerade die
frage gestellt habe ich beantworte sie
mal selber schärfer sie haben das
stichwort gegeben das passt genau
[Gelächter]
wie einfach ist das ist doch alles erst
entstandenen sozialen medien seien wir
doch jetzt mal ehrlich also
dass sich menschen so äußern das ist
erst in den sozialen medien so gewesen
das
haben wir anders ist dann ist
mittlerweile schon gut übernommen eine
sehr etablierte seit vielen jahren
bekannte tageszeitung schrieb neulich im
zusammenhang mit der cannabis diskussion
leitet die diskussion über mich ein der
kleinste polizeigewerkschaft hat der
welt so nun bin ich ja ein anerkanntes
kleinlebewesen ich mach das einfach
meine witze darüber dass ich nicht so
190 bin aber man muss sich das mal
vorstellen was soll das nun sein ist
dass journalismus also kein journalismus
wenn man eine gegenposition zu diesem
thema cannabis legalisierung einleitet
mit der kleinste polizeigewerkschaft
oder wild irgendwie umgehen das geht
schon davor nämlich trifft überhaupt
nicht geht ja ich lachte immer drüber
ich verbreite das sogar gelegentlich
noch
aber hat mich darüber lustig aber
trotzdem es ist der versuch eine an ein
gesprächspartner oder an jemanden der
eine andere position hat sozusagen durch
herabwürdigung von vornherein zu
diskreditieren ich mir sorgen galten in
der sich selbst weil ich glaube gar nur
mehr kennen wir erst richtig wenn wir
nicht nur anschauen also wenn ich es mal
sagen keine ältere weiße männer sind
einer sind natürlich betroffen sind aber
ist die betroffenheit biete ich an aber
wer wirklich betroffen sind sind eben
die junge menschen progressiv
marginalisierte gruppen minderheiten
frauen die tatsächlich noch viel stärker
und aggressiver attackiert werden zum
teil des männerchor schon genau aber
wieder sagen da haben wir jetzt aber
beim alten weiteren an mittlerweile ein
feindbild gefunden dass das ist ja das
ist ja sogar fast populärer zu sagen da
muss ich mich erklären welcher lage
junge warum ich das heißt wir können
noch keine wird er nach und als coupé
aber man kann ja über alte wenn wir über
alte weiße männer rené mir das wort
jetzt einfach mal an ich halte mich noch
nicht für einen alten weißen mann aber
ich kenne eine institution oder sogar
zwei oder ganz viele in der sehr sehr
viele alte weiße männer auch tätig sind
ja weiß angezogen hat aber ich bin kein
fantast ich bin weit entfernt von
selbsthilfegruppen dieser art aber ich
kann ihnen sagen ja ich mache mich gerne
darüber lustig